all right Ramsey is with us in Maryland
hi Ramsey how are you hey mr. Ramsey
thanks for taking my call
sure how can I help well first I just
want to let you know you know you're
really inspirational to me and I'm kind
of trying to get my friends involved and
listening to you and you know playing
our young adult lives the right way so
thank you for what you're doing for
everybody well thank you sir how can I
help today
so my girlfriend and I are currently
renting and listening to you and getting
inspired we've decided to move home for
about a year or two to do some really
hardcore saving our goal is in the next
three years to get a ring get a wedding
and you know get a house how old are you
so my question to you is you know we
currently get wise all we have is our
vehicles $20,000 each on each vehicle
and we want to go and we want to
maximize their savings and I'm trying to
convince us to maybe get rid of the
vehicles although I love my car very
much and so does she what is your
opinion on you know getting rid of those
to maximize saving for the next two
years how old are you I'm 26 and she's
25 okay and what's your what do you make
a year I make 92 what does she make
she's currently making 40,000 although
she's in school for nursing and will
graduate in the next two years and
hopefully make another 90 does what
would be wrong with just getting married
well we've been together coming up on
two years and I really want to hit that
to your mark and you know at least have
that under our belts before committing
and also I'd like to save up enough
money to pay for the cash in Wed are the
wedding in cash which would take about a
year $90,000 and she makes $40,000
mm-hmm okay listen you do whatever you
want to do it's certainly cool and I
appreciate you being a listener the way
I answer questions on this show is what
would I do if I was 26 years old and I
was in your shoes
so both cars and I would get married
tomorrow okay well she'd loved that
answer and I appreciated that and then
if you just want to celebrate six months
from now with a huge celebration that
looks like a wedding after you went to
the justice of the peace or the preacher
whatever she on the cheap right now and
you save up a bunch of money and you're
married yeah I mean after two years dude
you know you just got you got these
other things swimming around in your
heads all and you got to decide if this
is the girl that you're willing to move
back home for and you're willing to sell
the car for and you're willing to save
money and all this other stuff then this
is the girl you know get married it's
time do it
if this is it game on and cuz you guys
can work out of the dad on the cars or
you can work out of her she's gonna make
a great income as a nurse you're making
90 grand you're making a lot of money
for twenty six years old you're doing
great you got a good income you're
thinking about this you're using
critical thought process you're way
ahead of your friends in that sense and
so all I'm doing is just saying take
action you can do this get married
Celtic both cars and then start saving
like a crazy person and have a big
celebration six months from now called a
wedding this after the wedding thing the
wedding after the wedding thing and then
save up on my some cars and finish up
her school and it's game on you guys are
gonna be very very wealthy if you learn
to set priorities and execute on
decisions no I don't think you need to
backtrack and move on you're 26 you're
too far along you got things going
you're making good money there's nothing
holding you back here except some
decisions that's the only thing holding
you back you guys are rock stars man you
got on the run Ramsey good job man